we had a conversation and i remember it
was in a coffee shop
in studio city and you raised your voice
you weren't yelling but you were very
uh assertive you were very uh this was
important to you so i
that thus began a a conversation that
everyone had to hear uh
and it was like well i don't understand
because you you
[Laughter]
you you can't vision everyone in here
well you came from a vet i mean your
point was valid i remember
you said well i just like to work i like
to act i don't care if i'm on a bad show
i don't care if i'm in this i want to
perform i want to act i want to work and
we had two different
sort of ideas in fact i think we might
have talked about this and with
monica on the plane your mom has come up
a bunch between you and i yeah
it's an ongoing disagreement and i you
know i'm sort of like
maybe it's because i had success
with acting at a younger age well
younger but
and i kind of burn out and i was just
like i just don't i want
i have to love what i'm doing now maybe
and maybe all of a sudden
you hit your stride you went from you
know you were on
punk and you did growlings and all this
but you had to really we all had to earn
it
but you really had to grow and grow in
this role in this role and
and maybe you know you maybe you're
starting to get burned out of it now
you're understanding my point well um no
i think
for me and and by the way this this was
my point then and it remains my point
and by the way i'm not judgmental of
anyone
operating out of ego i operate on out of
ego in so many
realms of my life but i do recognize
that me wanting to be on breaking bad is
my ego
because i want people around town to
bump into me and say oh my god i love
your show right
and and i want to have died with having
been on these great shows but but then
another part of my brain recognizes my
children are never gonna see breaking
bad
they're not gonna rediscover it that it
goes away
it happened it goes away there's no
permanence
there's no it doesn't matter i'm gonna
die
and whether or not i leave behind me 700
episodes of amazing tv or 700 episodes
of terrible unwatchable tv
there's really no difference in that
outcome because no one beyond my life is
gonna
evaluate that so all my life really will
have been
is how much fun did i have making the
700 terrible or good
or or great episodes and how much did
they pay me
right i i think the rest i think is my
ego now and again i don't mind that
but here's like yes you like great shows
and my point to you is always like then
watch great shows
turn them on enjoy them you don't have
to be in them
look i i agree to a point i think my
approach was i think your kids will
watch them but
first of all it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter because you're dead no it
doesn't matter so
look of course there's ego i have a lot
of ego and [ __ ] i've worked on it and we
both have
i think for me it's like look a if i
couldn't afford like if i have a family
or if i couldn't afford something i will
do whatever it is
i don't care if they're doing i whatever
i'm not gonna
bad now the show i mean i will but i i
don't
i would do it i would do whatever it
takes to get have money to
provide but if i'm lucky enough where i
could make those decisions
i'd much rather spend my time on a show
that has that i'm
really proud of that is actually uh
i stretch i uh i'm challenged uh i i'm
like i can't wait to tell people to
watch this
as opposed to hey i'm on the show that i
don't even like
that's my point it's a great point but i
had this experience over the last
couple years which was i was on the
ranch on netflix
it has a humongous audience i've never
met a single person in hollywood that's
watched it
not one and i know several hundred
people in los angeles
and not one human being in our industry
has watched the ranch
now when i go do a live show around the
country
i meet a ton of people that like the
ranch that it has five million viewers
um so what i'm really doing is i'm
elevating
the opinion of my peers above the five
million people that watch the show and
enjoy it
first and foremost right i've decided i
want my peers approval
and not this five million people because
i think it goes without saying
neither of us are talking about a show
that has no audience then that's moot
yeah you can't be on a show with no
audience oh i've had those shows so
okay but they don't last you're not on
them for long yeah so my point is like
if you're on a show that has an audience
now you're talking about
what audience are you proud to have
and that's kind of ego because there's
no humans more valuable than another so
the five million people that love the
ranch versus the five million people
that love the parenthood
the only difference was some of those
people that love parenthood were my
peers so it felt
better my ego felt more stroked
by the fact that it was my peers as
opposed to these other five million
people so
once i acknowledge there's no hierarchy
in who likes it
you know or it'd be shitty of me to
think there's a hierarchy
i then go to okay so i probably wouldn't
watch the ranch none of my peers watch
the ranch
but to your point if i want to be proud
of the work i did
ironically i had some scenes in the
ranch that i think are the best i've
ever had as an actor like the
final of that show i actually had the
experience
i've had the experience on parenthood
where i'm trying to be emotional
and then i had like the the transcended
experience on the ranch where it was
like i was so emotional i was trying not
to be emotional which is what would
have really happened in that situation
and i was trying
not to cry and i was failing at that
and i've never had that experience
that's true yeah i haven't had it on
another project and there were
tons of other projects that were maybe
you know quote in our industry better
but my personal experience and my
personal accomplishment
probably peaked on that show that none
of my peers will watch
you